we can subconsciously embody the
reactions of somebody else this idea of
the introject is fascinating to me
because what it says is that if you
consume enough content if you read
enough books about people who have
embarked on certain kinds of Journeys
and made certain choices that at some
point you might inject some of their
personality and their responses and
subconsciously start making decisions
hopefully positive decisions on your own
behalf maybe having more appropriate
boundaries maybe taking better self-care
or care of other people and that without
without even realizing it you're
starting to make better choices on your
own behalf and then at some point you
move from the inject to a recognition
that wait it was me that made that
change I'm the one that managed to get
up a bit earlier and do a little bit
more or to be kinder in this context or
to listen a little bit better in this
context and over time we start to
ascribe those changes to ourselves